how are you doing with everything that's
going on I see you have the hat on and
stuck a tube going I'm rocking the tooth
because things are getting a little out
of control here I keep threatening to
like shave my head into like a mullet
type of situation yeah my partner Claire
is not thrilled about that notion
yesterday I had a moustache quote
unquote
so you know it's been a time of
experimentation shall we say totally so
before we talk about your sophomore
album which is so exciting I have it's
free
David that's not enough time we need to
get people notice I plan my
ex-girlfriends intervention in less than
an hour plus it'll weed out all the dead
weight what did it feel like what was
going on in your mind the moment the
credits started rolling it just sort of
brought back a lot of those feelings of
like I can't believe that it's that it's
done but I think also a lot of gratitude
to have to have landed in that company
and you know have grown into that family
and you know those are friendships and
relationships that I'll take with me the
rest of my life absolutely so a lot of
fans are hoping that there will be a
reunion a holiday special I keep poking
Dan every time I see him I'm like so
what do you think so from your
perspective would this be something
you'd want to do how do you feel about
that oh for sure the prevailing
sentiment is like if it's right then you
know that would be awesome and if it's
if it feels like it's a forced thing
then nobody really wants that you don't
want to be this show that came back for
like a subpar special so we have to be
right and it would have to be amazing
and and if those things all lined up I
mean that would be incredible but for
now know is focusing on his music career
releasing a sophomore album Gemini at
the end of the month
[Music]
tell us a little bit about it what was
going on in your heart and your mind
when you created that there are a lot of
little references to television the
entertainment industry the highs and
lows of that and and also just you know
sort of like it was a time where I was
falling in love so there was a lot of
like hopeful you know exuberant joyful
feelings along with you know a lot of
uncertainty buges hold on
[Music]
you know I'm a Gemini and I was like oh
there's a lot of like polarity in this
in this album
[Music]